that's super efficient it'll be Gobert  and penny Dennis read it beautifully  Rondo on the run emaki on the trail a  block underneath a ragged play and what  do they get out of it  O'Neal all the way to the hole five  blocks already for Anthony Davis  to see 25 on his 25th Burton one two  three go  they're telling them it's coming Jesus  going beyond the switch that's basic six  block and  here's what you know he's not thinking  about that ankle  this is commitment there's which Joubert  could catch Michael Cera plot ap got  another block megadate now ad do they  stop the ball he'll take it himself  nobody's  the ball which Miller will finally get  at ap looks back at the clock knows  what's in front of them and goes right  by coke there with an armbar of the  chest right until then Bru gives it away  kicked it away from himself  rice O'Neil on the break matches his  career back I don't know why you would  think that you got